This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。“保证真人”。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是英文的TWO。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他会得到他应得的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回味往事》(The Look Back at It) 播客中。对1979年来说，那对我是个大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回味往事》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·加姆斯主持的《难忘的教训》(Learn the Hard Way)。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都真的不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人随身携带一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《难忘的教训》。
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, my friends, let's talk about happiness. We're going to talk about what it means to be
大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》(The Psychology of Your 20s)，这是一个探讨我们二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客，新听众，老听众，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，当然，我们要剖析二十岁的心理学。今天，我的朋友们，让我们来谈谈幸福。我们要讨论什么是
happy. Seemingly very, very simple, right? Such a simple word, probably the first emotion that you think of when you think of emotions. And yet, if you are a human, you will understand that it is incredibly elusive at times and actually a lot more complex than we have been taught to think of it as. Humans have been talking about happiness for as long as humans could basically talk from, I don't know, ancient philosophers like Aristotle who believed happiness was like the highest human good to modern day neuroscientists who are obsessively studying the brain's reward system. Humanity has been on what feels like a relentless quest to uncover the secrets of a happy life since humanity was, I don't know, invented, existed since its origins.
快乐。看起来非常非常简单，对吧？这样一个简单的词，可能是你想到情绪时脑海中浮现的第一个词。然而，如果你是一个人类，你就会明白，它有时是如此难以捉摸，而且实际上比我们被教导认为的要复杂得多。自从人类基本上能够说话起，人类就一直在谈论幸福，比如，古希腊哲学家亚里士多德认为幸福是人类最高的善，再到现代神经科学家沉迷于研究大脑的奖励系统。自从人类被发明、自起源以来，人类就一直在进行一场感觉像是永无止境的探索，以揭开幸福生活的秘密。
But I personally think finding happiness these days, and like I'm talking real happiness, like real deep life satisfaction and contentment and joy is really, really hard. We are bombarded with images of the perfect lives we see on social media. There is this increasingly wide gap between rich and poor. We are often convinced that happiness is like a destination that we can reach if we just work hard enough, if we buy the right things, if we achieve the right milestones. and it's probably no surprise that this narrow view is a huge part of the problem. It sets us up for disappointment.
但我个人认为，如今寻找幸福——我是指真正的幸福，比如真正深刻的生活满意度、满足感和快乐——真的非常非常难我们在社交媒体上轰动地看到了各种完美生活的画面。贫富差距越来越大。我们常常确信，幸福就像一个目的地，只要我们足够努力工作，如果我们买对了东西，如果我们达成了正确的里程碑，我们就能到达那里。这并不奇怪，这种狭隘的观点正是问题的很大一部分。它让我们为失望做好了准备。
It makes us feel like failures when we don't reach the same level as the people we see online or we aren't able to have the same lifestyle as people making millions and millions of dollars. And I think it also, I think a bigger issue with how we view happiness right now is it's a singular thing. Happiness is a state, a singular state that we want to be in as much as possible. and I don't think that we really have an appreciation for how perhaps less positive emotions actually contribute to satisfaction and contribute to emotional well-being. I think we just think of happiness as the ultimate goal without realizing everything that it takes to get there and everything that we don't actually require to be happy. So today we are going to break down the myths, misconceptions,
当我们达不到我们在网上看到的人们的水平，或者无法拥有年入数百万美元的人的生活方式时，它让我们觉得自己是失败者。而且我认为，我们目前看待幸福的方式还有一个更大的问题，那就是它是一个单一的东西。幸福是一种状态，是我们尽可能想要处于的一种单一状态。我不认为我们真正理解那些不那么积极的情绪实际上是如何促进满足感和促进情绪健康的。我认为我们只是把幸福当作最终目标，却没有意识到实现它所需要的一切，以及我们实际上并不需要什么就能感到幸福。所以今天我们将打破这些神话、误解，
and of course the science and psychology of truth. genuine lasting happiness. And we're also going to go beyond quick fixes. Quick fixes for feeling more happy. You know, everyone knows that seeing your friends and exercising and meditating and journaling is going to make you feel good. But what about some deeper psychologically back strategies that can actually make this, make happiness more deeply ingrained and more effective to actually find. That's what I really want to talk about. Some of the things that are perhaps hidden in the psychology research, some of the strategies that are hidden in the academia that I think should be more popularized, that I think we should be talking about more when we talk about a happy life. So
当然还有关于真正持久幸福的真相的科学与心理学。我们还将超越快速解决方法。让自己感觉更快乐的快速方法。你知道，每个人都知道见朋友、锻炼、冥想和写日记会让你感觉良好。但是那些更深层的、有心理学支持的策略呢？它们实际上能让这种感觉、让幸福更根深蒂固，并且在实际寻找时更有效。这正是我真正想谈论的。有些东西也许隐藏在心理学研究中，有些策略隐藏在学术界中，我认为它们应该更受欢迎，我认为当我们谈论幸福生活时，我们应该更多地谈论它们。所以
there is so much that we're going to discuss, we're going to discuss whether like money makes you happier. We're going to discuss whether it's possible to be happy, always the happiest country in the world, the happiest people in the world, everything you can think of that has to do with this topic we will be there. We're going to sink our teeth into it. So without further ado, let's get into it. So first things first, and I know this is going to sound so silly and so basic, but what are we actually talking about when we talk about happiness? What do we actually mean here? Again, I know it sounds silly. I know we probably think we have a good grasp on this by now, but just like, humor me for a second, okay? The field we actually need to turn to is not just the field
我们要讨论的内容太多了，我们将讨论诸如金钱是否能让你更快乐。我们将讨论是否有可能永远快乐，世界上最快乐的国家，世界上最快乐的人，你能想到的所有与这个话题有关的事情，我们都会涉猎。我们要深入探讨。废话不多说，让我们开始吧。首先第一件事听起来可能很傻很基础，但当我们谈论幸福时，我们究竟在谈什么？我们在这里究竟是什么意思？再说一次，我知道这听起来很傻。我知道我们可能认为我们现在对此有了很好的理解，但请迁就我一下，好吗？我们真正需要转向的领域不仅仅是
of psychology, but the field of positive psychology. Positive psychology is basically like a unique branch of this discipline that is dedicated to studying what makes life most worth living and also what makes people happy. And that honestly sounds like the most amazing job ever. Like imagine your only job is just to figure out how to be a happier person. But researchers in this space have spent decades It's trying to find, trying to measure, trying to define happiness amongst other things. And they found that in reality, it's a lot more than just a single emotion as we've been taught to view it as. There's actually two types of happiness, hedonic and eudamonic happiness. Hedonic happiness is, I think, the kind of happiness most of us initially think of.
心理学领域，而是积极心理学领域。积极心理学基本上是该学科的一个独特分支，致力于研究什么让生活最值得过，以及什么让人快乐。这听起来真是有史以来最棒的工作。就像想象你唯一的工作就是弄清楚如何成为一个更快乐的人。但这个领域的空间研究人员花了数十年时间试图找到、试图衡量、试图定义幸福以及其他事情。他们发现，现实中，它远不止我们被教导的那种单一情绪。实际上有两种类型的幸福：享乐主义幸福和eudaimonic（实现自我价值的）幸福。享乐主义幸福，我认为是我们大多数人最初想到的那种幸福。
It's basically the pursuit of pleasure and the avoidance of pain. very like a very simple equation. This is like a combination of the feel good stuff like the rush you get from a compliment, the satisfaction of a delicious meal, you know, going on a roller coaster, and then the subtraction of negative stuff like not feeling pain, not feeling sad, not feeling heartbreak. This is basically a utilitarian notion of happiness. We can basically determine how happy someone is by summing up the pleasures and subtracting the pains. The experience of positive effect, just like the moment to moment feeling of joy, that is hedonic happiness. But the problem is, is that those moments are often very short-lived and they're often tied to external stimuli.
它基本上是追求快乐和逃避痛苦。非常像一个非常简单的方程式。这就像是感觉良好的东西的组合，比如赞美带给你的冲动，美味食物的满足感，你知道的，坐过山车，然后减去消极的东西，比如不感到痛苦，不感到悲伤，不感到心碎。这基本上是一种功利主义的幸福观。我们基本上可以通过将快乐相加并减去痛苦来决定某人有多快乐。积极情感的体验，就像一分一秒的快乐感觉，这就是享乐主义幸福。但问题是，这些时刻往往非常短暂，而且往往与外部刺激挂钩。
Hadonic happiness is really focused on the pleasure or the joy that we get from having things, seeing things, being around certain people, eunmonic happiness, on the other hand, it's about living a life of meaning and purpose and self-realization, even if maybe day-to-day you aren't experiencing as many external highs. This concept really at first started with Aristotle. We've already said his name once. He's definitely like a key person in this discussion, but he essentially suggested way back on the day that true well-being doesn't come from
享乐主义幸福真正关注的是我们从拥有事物、看到事物、与某些人在一起中获得的快乐或喜悦；另一方面，实现自我价值的幸福（eudaimonic happiness），则是关于过一种充满意义、目的和自我实现的生活，即使可能在日常生活中你并没有经历那么多的外部高潮。这个概念最初始于亚里士多德。我们已经说过他一次名字了。他绝对是这场讨论中的关键人物，但他在当时本质上提出，真正的幸福并非来自
pleasure alone, but it comes from fulfilling your deeply seated potential and living a life aligned with your values. Think of like the profound sense of pride that a parent feels watching their child graduate or like the quiet contentment of like a volunteer who has dedicated their life to a cause they believe in even when it was hard. Think about people who train for multi-day hikes or triathlons and it's hard work and it's painful and to be honest it probably really sucks but then they complete it and they just feel this deep sense of accomplishment even if they hurt all over these moments may not always be easy they're definitely not filled to the brim with pleasure but they are incredibly rewarding on a much deeper level and they are a more sustainable form of happiness
单纯的快乐，而是来自发挥你深藏的潜力，过一种与你的价值观相一致的生活。想想父母看着孩子毕业时感受到的那种深烈的自豪感，或者一个将一生奉献给她所信仰的事业的志愿者所拥有的那种平静的满足感，即使这过程很艰难。想想那些为多日徒步旅行或铁人三项进行训练的人们，这是一项艰苦的工作，充满痛苦，说实话，可能真的很糟糕，但随后他们完成了，他们只是感到了这种深深的成就感，即使他们浑身酸痛。这些时刻可能并不总是容易的，它们绝对不是满满的快乐，但它们在更深层次上极具回报，而且它们是一种更可持续的幸福形式。
Now, both types hedonic and eudamonic are incredibly important for overall well-being, but they contribute to our lives just simply in different ways. A great framework for understanding these different facets, which you've probably heard of if you've ever spent any time in positive psychology or psychology in general is the perma model, which was developed by the psychologist, Dr. Martin Stilgman. He is like a key figure within the field of positive psychology, and he basically proposed that, again,
现在，这两种类型——享乐主义幸福和实现自我价值的幸福——对于整体福祉都非常重要，但它们只是以不同的方式对我们的生活做出贡献。一个理解这些不同方面的伟大框架——如果你在积极心理学或一般心理学中度过任何时间，你可能听说过——就是PERMA模型，由心理学家马丁·塞利格曼博士(Dr. Martin Seligman)开发。他是积极心理学领域的关键人物，他基本上提出，再次强调，
well-being is not a single feeling. We know that by now, but it is built on five measurable elements. And these five elements obviously create the acronym, Perma. So let's start with P. P is positive emotions. This covers like the hedonic side of happiness, the good feelings of hope, being in love, feeling grateful, giggling, smiling, all those like nice, soft, floaty feelings that we experience, hopefully day to day. E is engagement. This is the state of flow. We talk about this all the time.
福祉不是单一的感觉。我们现在知道了这一点，但它是建立在五个可衡量的要素之上的。这五个要素显然构成了首字母缩写PERMA。让我们从P开始。P是积极情绪(Positive emotions)。这涵盖了幸福的享乐主义方面，即希望、坠入爱河、感恩、咯咯笑、微笑等美好感觉，所有这些美好、柔软、飘飘然的感觉，我们希望能日复一日地体验到。E是投入(Engagement)。这是心流状态。我们一直在谈论这个。
It's the state where you are so completely mesmerized, absorbed, challenged by an activity, but also equally enthralled by it, that you lose all sense of time and self. Now, we find this in our hobbies. We find it in our creative pursuits. We find it in challenging work. We also find it when we are pursuing or living out our purpose. Actually, one of the initials, like conceptions of flow or how we initially discovered flow was through this Russian psychologist
这是一种你被一项活动完全迷住、全神贯注、充满挑战，但同时也同样被它深深吸引，以至于你失去了所有时间和自我感的状态。现在，我们在爱好中找到这一点。我们在创造性追求中找到它。我们在具有挑战性的工作中找到它。当我们追求或践行我们的目标时，我们也会找到它。事实上，对心流的最初构想之一，或者我们最初是如何发现心流的，是通过这位俄罗斯心理学家
who wanted to figure out what highly successful people all had in common, whether they were ballerinas, whether they were CEOs, whether they were athletes, doctors, whatever it was, and all of them had this flow relationship with their work. I feel like this one's very easily explainable. It's just relationships. There are probably very few, if not no people in this world. who could be seriously happy without having strong positive relationships with other people. That is a fundamental human need.
他想弄清楚高度成功的人有什么共同点，无论是芭蕾舞演员、首席执行官、运动员、医生，无论是什么，他们所有人都与他们的工作有着这种心流关系。我觉得这个很容易解释。这就是人际关系。世界上可能很少有，甚至没有这样的人：如果没有与其他人建立牢固的积极关系，他们就能真正快乐。这是人类的基本需求。
And it's also one of the most powerful predictors of well-being. What I really like about this perma model is the inclusion of this and the fact that happiness is not a solo experience. It's a joint one, which I love. M, similar to E, is meaning, having a sense of purpose, a sense of belonging to something bigger than you, having it maybe a cause that you're working towards, a spiritual practice, something that tells you like, oh, I'm here for a reason. Existence does have a point and I'm living out that point.
这也是福祉的最强预测指标之一。我非常喜欢这个PERMA模型的地方在于它包含了这一点，即幸福不是一个人的体验，而是一个共同的体验，我非常喜欢这一点。M，类似于E，是意义(Meaning)，拥有目标感，有一种属于比你更宏大的事物的归属感，也许拥有一个你正在努力实现的事业，一种精神实践，某种告诉你“哦，我来这里是有原因的。存在是有意义的，我正在践行这个意义”的东西。
And finally, A, A is accomplishment, the feeling of striving for and achieving goals. This provides us with a sense of mastery. It provides us with a sense of competence, which is also another essential human need. So according to this theory, true happiness again it isn't one thing it's a blend of all these elements research has consistently shown that individuals who score highly or even moderately on all measures of perma tend to report greater life satisfaction greater over well-being they are happier compared to people who score you know low on these things or also compared to people who score really high on just a few of these things So for example, someone might make a lot of money and they might have seemingly a lot of friends and get invited to a lot of parties and events.
最后是A，A是成就(Accomplishment)，即为目标奋斗并实现目标的感受。这为我们提供了一种掌控感。它为我们提供了一种能力感，这也是人类的另一种基本需求。因此，根据这个理论，真正的幸福再次说明它不是一件事，而是所有这些要素的融合。研究一致表明，在所有PERMA测量指标上得分较高甚至中等的个人，往往会报告更高的生活满意度、更高的整体福祉。与在这些事情上得分较低的人相比，或者与仅在其中几项上得分非常高的人相比，他们更快乐。
But if they don't have meaning or many day-to-day positive emotions, they may actually be less happy than someone who makes a lot less money, maybe only has a few close friends, but has a strong reason for being. It has a strong sense of personal accomplishment and a strong sense of engagement in their life. It has to be a blend, right? It's like trying to make a cake only with two of the ingredients you need. What this theory really says is you need all of them. There's so much research on happiness and well-being. And I think it really begs the question, like, can happiness actually ever be measured? Like, you know, I just talked about this comparison between these two people.
所以，举个例子，一个人可能会赚很多钱，表面上可能有很多朋友，并被邀请参加很多派对和活动。但如果他们没有意义，或者没有很多日常的积极情绪，他们实际上可能不如一个赚得少得多、可能只有几个密友、但有强烈的生存理由的人快乐。它具有强烈的个人成就感和对生活的强烈投入感。它必须是一个融合，对吧？这就像试图只用你需要的两种原料来做一个蛋糕。这个理论真正要说的是，你需要所有的原料。关于幸福和福祉的研究非常多。我想这确实引发了一个问题，即幸福真的能被测量吗？就像，你知道的，我刚刚谈到了这两个人之间的这种比较。
Is that comparison actually possible? Is there like statistically, scientifically, scientifically, mathematically, is there, there's the happiest person in the world actually? exist and could we find them? Well, here's the thing. Happiness can be studied because of its components can be measured, but it's really crucial to understand a key distinction. We can't actually directly measure the feeling of happiness itself. Like, we haven't actually gotten to that point. We can only really measure like the behavioral and psychological signifiers that indicate a happy or flourishing life. So, for example, you know, you can't directly measure sickness in somebody, but you can't
这种比较真的可能吗？是否存在，在统计学上、科学上、数学上，世界上最快乐的人真的存在，我们能找到他们吗？好吧，事情是这样的。幸福之所以可以被研究，是因为它的组成部分是可以被测量的，但理解一个关键区别至关重要。我们实际上无法直接测量幸福感本身。就像，我们实际上还没有达到那个地步。我们只能真正测量表明幸福或繁荣生活的行为和心理指标。所以，例如，你知道，你无法直接测量某人生病与否，但你
can measure a person's body temperature or a person's white blood cell count, which is an indicator. And these, you know, things like purpose and relationships and engagement, they are the body temperature, the white blood cell count of happiness. And this is where models like Perma become so powerful. The elements within this model, they're all observable, they're all quantifiable. That's what makes it a really great psychological tool to understand perhaps where someone may be lacking or why someone may be flourishing more than another person. So scientifically, we can measure individual indicators of happiness, but in terms of finding the happiest person in the world, it's going to be very, very hard because happiness, it remains completely subjective. It is
可以测量一个人的体温或白细胞计数，这是一个指标。这些东西，比如目标、人际关系和投入，它们就是幸福的体温和白细胞计数。这就是像PERMA这样的模型变得如此强大的地方。该模型中的元素都是可观察的、可量化的。这正是它成为一个非常伟大的心理学工具的原因，可以用来了解某人可能在哪里有所欠缺，或者为什么某人可能比另一个人更繁荣。因此，在科学上，我们可以测量幸福的个体指标，但在寻找世界上最快乐的人方面，这将非常非常困难，因为幸福仍然完全是主观的。它是
experienced differently between people, which is why discussions around like optimism versus pessimism sometimes come up. It's a core question, you know, at the center of happiness research. Are some people just inherently more happy than others? Are they just born that way? Well, it turns out some part of that is true. Some people do have a genetic predisposition to finding better engagement, having more positive emotions, but it's a bit more complicated. Our level of happiness and the way we experience perma, basically, is influenced by a combination of genetics, life circumstances, and intentional activities. So there's this thing called the happiness set point theory. It was famously proposed by the researcher, Professor Sonia Lubramiski.
每个人体验都不同，这就是为什么有时会出现乐观主义与悲观主义的讨论。这是幸福研究核心的一个核心问题。有些人是否只是天生比其他人更快乐？他们是不是天生就是这样？好吧，事实证明，其中一部分是真的。有些人确实对找到更好的投入、拥有更多的积极情绪具有基因倾向，但事情要复杂一些。我们的幸福水平以及我们体验PERMA的方式，基本上受到基因、生活环境和刻意活动相结合的影响。所以有一个叫做幸福设定点理论（happiness set point theory）的东西。它由研究人员索尼娅·柳博米斯基（Sonia Lyubomirsky）教授提出。
She basically suggests that a significant portion of our happiness around 50% is kind of something we're born with. It's determined by our genes. We are born with a genetically determined baseline level of happiness that we tend to return to even after major life events. And we don't really know any differently. Think about, you know, there are certain people you know who just always seem really cheerful, always seem really resilient, they always bounce back really quickly from setbacks. And then there are other people you know who tend to be more reserved, super cautious, who tend to just find themselves lingering on setbacks even when they don't want to. Some of this isn't a matter of choice. A significant part of this is inherited. We know that through
她基本上表明，我们幸福感的很大一部分——大约50%——某种程度上是我们天生带来的。它由我们的基因决定。我们生来就有一个由基因决定的基准幸福水平，即使在经历了重大的生活事件后，我们也往往会回到这个水平。我们真的不知道有什么不同。想想看，你知道某些人总是显得非常开朗，总是显得非常有韧性，他们总能从挫折中迅速恢复过来。然后你知道其他人往往更内敛，超级谨慎，即使在他们不想的时候也往往发现自己对挫折念念不忘。其中一些不是选择的问题。很大一部分是遗传的。我们通过
twin studies. Studies comparing identical twins and fraternal twins consistently show that identical twins have far more similar levels of happiness, even when they've been raised in different families. Considering that identical twins share 100% of their genes of DNA and fraternal twins only share about 50% this suggests that a substantial portion of our happiness, I'm not going to say substantial, a portion of our happiness is hardwired into our DNA. And this genetic component explains why even after major life events, both negative and positive, we tend to return to our baseline level of happiness over time. So this really brings us to life circumstances.
双胞胎研究了解到了这一点。对同卵双胞胎和异卵双胞胎的比较研究一致表明，同卵双胞胎的幸福水平要相似得多，即使他们在不同的家庭中长大。考虑到同卵双胞胎共享100%的基因DNA，而异卵双胞胎只共享大约50%，这表明我们幸福感的很大一部分——我不会说大部分，但很大一部分——是硬编码到我们的DNA中的。这种基因成分解释了为什么即使在经历了重大生活事件（无论是负面的还是正面的）之后，随着时间的推移，我们往往会回到幸福的基准水平。所以这真的把我们带到了生活环境。
Now, live circumstances actually make up the smallest part of this equation. They tend to contribute to only about 10% of our overall happiness and well-being. So life circumstances, it includes all the external factors that make up our lives. So income, marital status, health, even our appearance. Logically, we often assume these factors have the biggest impact on our happiness. You know, after all, like, a. pay raise, a new home, a new relationship, feeling good in your body, that feels like it would make us significantly happier for the long haul. However, in reality, it's a different story.
现在，生活环境实际上只占这个方程式中最小的部分。它们往往只占我们整体幸福感的大约10%。所以生活环境包括构成我们生活的所有外部因素。因此包括收入、婚姻状况、健康，甚至我们的外表。从逻辑上讲，我们通常认为这些因素对我们的幸福影响最大。你知道，毕竟，加薪、新家、新恋情、身体感觉良好，感觉会让我们长期显著地感到更快乐。然而，在现实中，情况却不同。
This is largely due to a phenomenon we know as hedonic adaption. We quickly get used to new circumstances whether they're good or bad. So like the excitement of a new car or a big salary feels amazing for a little while. And then the feeling kind of fades and we return to our emotional basis. This doesn't mean that these things don't matter at all. You know, financial security, for example, is crucial for reducing stress and can seriously lift someone's well-being if they are, you know, in poverty. But the impact on our long-term happiness after we've had this benefit or had this thing for a while does tend to become limited and does tend to drop off. The most empowering and actionable part of this model. And let me just say it is a model. It's not always going to be 100%. It's definitely like there is evidence for and against it, but the most actionable part of this model is made up of our intentional activities. What we choose to do with our time. This 40% represents the portion of our happiness that is entirely within our control. And it all rests on the conscious things we do and we think about on a regular basis. So this category
这主要是由于一种被称为享乐适应（hedonic adaptation）的现象。我们很快就会习惯新的环境，无论是好是坏。所以像一辆新车或丰厚薪水的兴奋感感觉很棒一段时间。然后这种感觉有点消退，我们回到了情绪基准。这并不意味着这些事情完全不重要。你知道，例如，财务安全对于减轻压力至关重要，如果有人处于贫困之中，它可以极大地提升某人的福祉。但在我们获得了这个好处或拥有了这件事一段时间后，对我们长期幸福的影响往往变得有限并呈下降趋势。这个模型中最具赋权和可操作性的部分。让我这么说吧，它是一个模型。它并不总是100%正确，它绝对有支持和反对的证据，但这个模型中最具可操作性的部分是由我们的刻意活动组成的。我们如何选择利用我们的时间。这40%代表了完全在我们控制之中的幸福部分。它完全取决于我们定期做的和思考的有意识的事情。所以这个类别
includes things like behavioral activities. So slowing down, engaging. aging an acts of kindness, exercising regularly, spending time in nature, making art, giving back to the community, cognitive activities, practicing gratitude, reframing negative thoughts, cultivating an optimistic mindset, and then volitional activities, committing to meaningful goals, increasing our education levels, building strong relationships, savoring positive. experiences. By consistently engaging in these intentional activities, we can deliberately, actively increase our levels of happiness regardless of our genetic set point and regardless to a degree of our life circumstances. In short, you can't change your genes, you can't predict your circumstances, but having the right mindset and your daily habits and choices are still incredibly powerful tools for cultivating lasting joy and well-being. And I think that the thing is, is that even though genetics might seem like it makes up a bigger
包括诸如行为活动之类的事情。因此，放慢脚步，参与善举，定期锻炼，在大自然中度过时光，创作艺术，回馈社会，认知活动，练习感恩，重新构想负面想法，培养乐观的心态，以及意志活动，致力于有意义的目标，提高我们的教育水平，建立牢固的关系，品味积极的体验。通过持续参与这些刻意活动，我们可以刻意地、积极地提高我们的幸福水平，而不管我们的基因设定点如何，在某种程度上也不管我们的生活环境如何。简而言之，你无法改变你的基因，你无法预测你的环境，但拥有正确的思维方式以及你的日常习惯和选择仍然是培养持久快乐和福祉的极其强大的工具。我认为事情是这样的，尽管基因可能占了更大的一片蛋糕，但并没有哪一个人被完全注定在生命的每一个时刻都不快乐。因此，这40%的刻意事情仍然可以为每个人改变平衡，扭转局面。
slice of the pie, there's not a single person who was like completely determined to be unhappy in every single moment of their life. So that 40% of intentional things can still, for every single person, shift the balance and shift the scales for them. Okay, we're going to take a short break here, but when we return, let's talk about some of the myths you may have seen swirling around about happiness recently. You know, are we becoming less happy? Will making a lot of money make you more happy? Well, hopefully I have some answers to those very questions, plus, of course, some tips.
好了，我们在这里稍作休息，但当我们回来时，让我们来谈谈你最近可能看到的围绕幸福的一些神话。你知道，我们变得不那么快乐了吗？赚很多钱会让你更快乐吗？好吧，希望我对这些问题有一些答案，当然还有一些建议。所以请继续关注我们。《2%》。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家等进行对话，以超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题
So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator. available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked
都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更 happier、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是在I-Heart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听TWO percent。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他故事中惊人的不一致之处。这开启了长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。
doubt about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family The court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in soons, correct? I doctored the test once.
这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·莱斯皮安（Greg Lespian）和迈克尔·马林奇尼（Michael Marincini）。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lespian and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
这就是《爱情陷阱》(Love Trap)。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着季节的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。女士们先生们，来自马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在正义在亚利桑那州得到伸张之前，这还没完。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。每个男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在这个新一季的《闺蜜》中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me?
警察似乎并不在意。所以他们自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的惩罚。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客中收听《闺蜜》。
The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed, I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts,
或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯(Diana Ross)在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小姬姆(Lil Kim)的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小姬姆有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回味往事》播客中找到答案。
or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-taped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bulls, Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）一起大谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我很乐意一整天都谈论快克，但只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，在这一点上，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看到有一条贯穿线。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second. episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
我们现在桌上还有艾滋病。所以，当你结束那个句子时。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回味往事》。我最近一直在和我的朋友们进行很多讨论。关于，我们是不是一个悲伤的一代？这一代人是否注定要受苦，因为世界感觉就像是在着火？
We also have AIDS on the table right now. So, that you're finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I've recently been having a lot of discussions with my friends recently. about, like, are we a sad a generation? Is this generation just bound to suffer because of the fact that the world literally feels like it's on fire?
在某些情况下，在过去的几年里，实际上已经着火了。似乎每次我们聚会时，就像，我前几天和朋友在海滩上，我在邦迪海滩，就像我们讨论的第一件事是，你看到新闻里发生的可怕事情了吗？你看到那个政府这次在做什么了吗？我有没有告诉你这些可怕的抗议活动以及我的工作有多糟糕，我工作有多过度，哦，你知道我的财务状况很糟糕，我失去了工作，等等等等，这就像我们每次出去玩，我们必须解决的第一件事就是
And in some cases, in the past couple of years, has literally been on fire. It seems like every time we catch up, like, I was at the beach with my friends, I was at Bondo Beach the other day, and it's like the first thing we discussed is like, did you see the horrible thing that happened in the news? Did you see what, like, that government is doing this time? did I tell you about like these awful protests and how awful my job is and however worked I am and oh that like you know my financial situation is bad and I've lost my job and blah blah it's like every single time we hang out the first thing we have to just get out of the way is like
好吧，让我们先谈谈新闻有多糟糕以及世界的现状有多糟糕，然后尽可能长时间地假装，或者试图从中得到喘息，并试图假装它没有让每个人日复一日地变得更加痛苦，目前很难保持清醒。我一直在琢磨这件事，可能是因为社交媒体，以及我认为人们对他们正在挣扎的事实更加开放，并且真正承认世界环境相当严峻？我们作为一个集体变得不快乐了吗？这是，幸福水平发生了明显的变化吗？所以有几组人，几个组织
all right let's just address how shit the news is and how terrible the current state of the world is and you know pretend for as long as we can or like try and get a respite from it and try and pretend that it's not making everyone more miserable day by day, it's hard to kind of keep your head above water at the moment. I've really been like pondering it, probably because of social media and how I think people are being more open about the fact that they're struggling and are like really acknowledging that the circumstances of the world are pretty dire? Are we becoming less happy as a collective? Is this, has there been a noticeable change in happiness levels. So there are a couple of groups, a couple of organizations
年复一年地试图回答这个非常问题。他们还做了大量关于金钱、经济和幸福如何交织在一起的工作。他们还评估了每个国家的幸福水平。事实证明，顺便说一句，世界上最快乐的国家是芬兰，连续八年。截至2025年，如果你来自芬兰，请告诉我你们国家发生了什么导致这种情况，因为你们真的是一群快乐的人。但其中一个尝试是《世界幸福报告》。它由牛津大学年复一年地与——我认为是乐施会或联合国之一——以及盖洛普这家调查公司合作进行调查。是的，他们做调查和民意测验。结果显示，过去几十年平均幸福水平相当稳定
that attempt to answer this very question year after year. They also do a bunch of work around how money, economics and happiness tied together. And they also assess happiness levels in each country. Turns out the happiest country in the world, by the way, is Finland eight years in a row. As of 2025, if you're from Finland, tell me what's happening in your country that is making that the case because you guys are some happy folks. But one of these attempts is the World Happiness Report. It's conducted year after year by the University of Oxford in collaboration with, I think it's either Oxfam or the UN and then also Gallup, the like survey company surveys. Yeah, they do like surveys and polls. And the results have shown a pretty stable average level of happiness
。每个人都坐在70分左右。不像50分那样事情变得糟糕，绝对不是100分。然而，最近的分析揭示了一个非常令人担忧的趋势，特别是在年轻一代中。自2010年左右以来，年轻人的幸福感和生活满意度出现了明显的下降。自这些研究进行以来，在无数国家中，年轻人首次不如他们的年长同行快乐。
over the past few decades. Everyone's kind of sitting around like the 70 mark. Like not 50 where things are getting terrible, definitely not 100. However, recent analysis has revealed a really concerning trend, particularly in younger generations. There have been and has been a noticeable decline in happiness and the life satisfaction of young people since around 2010. For the first time, since these studies have been conducted, in countless countries, young adults are less happy than their older counterparts.
显然，我们希望解决每一个年龄段和每一个人口群中的快乐与不快乐。但我们某种程度上一直认为我们的青春是这个美好的金色泡沫，或者应该对尽可能多的人来说是这个美好的金色泡沫。因此，这个金色泡沫显然已经破裂的事实让很多人超级担忧。研究人员指出了许多不同的因素，但当然，这仍在讨论中。社交媒体的兴起是一个大问题。每个人都想把责任归咎于此。在某些方面，我确实认为它负有责任。就像科技的飞速发展使得在不与他人进行比较的情况下主观体验幸福变得非常困难。
And obviously, we want to address happiness and unhappiness in every single age group and every single population. But we've kind of always assumed that our youth is like this nice golden bubble or should be this nice golden bubble for as many people as possible. So the fact that that golden bubble has seemingly burst is obviously making a lot of people super concerned. Researchers point to a lot of different factors, but of course, like it's an ongoing discussion. The rise of social media is a big one. Everyone kind of wants to pin on that. And in some ways, I do think it's responsible. Like the rapid emergence of technology has made it really hard to experience happiness subjectively without comparing it to someone else.
但最近有一些文章和书籍说，指责社交媒体其实完全是一个红鲱鱼（转移视线）。就像，当你仔细看时，它的影响并不像经济状况或对未来的乐观情绪等其他事情那么严重。但人们确实继续说它是2024年世界幸福报告中的一个主要竞争者。他们确实设法将年轻人福祉的下降与互联网使用的增加明确联系起来。我实际上看到了国家经济研究局最近的一篇文章，其中指出年轻人的福祉出现了具体的崩溃，尤其是女性，大约在2013年。这与什么相吻合？这与智能手机的广泛采用相吻合。但再次强调，经济困境、政治不稳定感、日益增加的孤独感。这些也都是罪魁祸首。我认为科技只是最容易将责任归咎于的东西，因为它是过去几十年中对社会改变最迅速的东西。但再次回到这一点，真正令人担忧的是它主要是年轻人。我们再次根据这个非常著名的幸福U型曲线采用了这种信念，即在你十几岁末和二十多岁时，你应该成为你自己最快乐的版本。
but there have been recent articles and books written which are saying blaming social media is actually just like a complete red herring. Like it's really, when you look at it, the impact of it is not as severe as other things like economic conditions or a sense of optimism for the future. But people do continue to say that it is a main contender in the 2024 World Happiness Report. They did manage to explicitly link the decline in youth well-being to increased internet usage. I actually saw a recent article from the National Bureau of Economic
但最近有一些文章和书籍指出，将社交媒体归咎于此完全是一个烟雾弹。当你仔细观察时，其影响并不像经济状况或对未来的乐观情绪等其他因素那么严重。但人们仍然坚持认为它是2024年世界幸福报告中的一个主要影响因素。他们确实成功地将青少年福祉的下降与互联网使用率的增加直接联系起来。我实际上最近看到了国家经济局的一篇文章
Research, which noted a specific collapse in the well-being of young people, especially women around 2013. What did that coincide with? That coincided with the widespread adoption of smartphones. But again, economic hardship, a sense of political instability, increased loneliness. They are all also to blame. I think technology is just the easiest one to kind of pin it on because it is the thing that is most rapidly, I think, changed about society in the last couple of decades. But again, back to this is that what's really concerning is that it's mainly young people. And we have, again, always adopted this belief based on this very famous U-shaped curve of happiness that you should be the happiest version of yourself in your late teens and in your 20s.
研究指出，年轻人的幸福感出现了特定的大幅崩塌，尤其是女性在2013年前后。这与什么同时发生？这与智能手机的广泛普及不谋而合。但同样，经济困顿、政治不稳定感、日益加剧的孤独感，这些也都难辞其咎。我认为科技只是最容易被指责的对象，因为它是过去几十年来社会中变化最快的事物。但话说回来，真正令人担忧的是受影响的主要是年轻人。而且我们再次一直秉持着一种基于著名的“幸福U型曲线”的信念，即你在十几岁到二十多岁时应该是最幸福的。
and, you know, it's midlife where you should be really starting to, perhaps feeling the pressures of career and family and financial responsibilities. A lot of that is now moving up. People are adopting this sense of, like, anxiety and stress and fear a lot earlier. And there are so many explanations for that. But I feel like our 20s are no longer this time for experimentation and this time to be a little bit careful. it feels like you have to get serious a lot quicker. It's also why we're starting to see people have quarter-life crises. That's like a new term that's only been introduced in the last maybe 15 years.
你知道，正是在中年时期，你本该真正开始感受到来自职业、家庭和经济责任的压力。而现在，很多压力都提前了。人们更早地开始接受这种焦虑、压力和恐惧感。对此有太多的解释。但我觉得，我们的二十岁不再是一段用于尝试、可以稍稍小心翼翼的时期了。感觉你必须更快地严肃起来。这也是为什么我们开始看到人们经历“四分之一人生危机”。这是一个可能在过去15年里才出现的新词。
It used to always be about the midlife crisis, this point where people really had this like moment of clarity and confusion and just like existential dread around what their life really meant and what they really wanted out of their life. that's happening earlier. People are feeling less positive. And the thing is, is that we're not seeing much of a change in like that midlife low point. People like in the later years are still kind of experiencing the same levels of happiness, which is a good thing. But it is really going to show that there is this remarkable shift. The early 20s high point is no longer the is no longer the norm.
过去人们总是在谈论中年危机，这是人们在这一人生节点上，对生活真正的意义以及自己对生活的真正诉求，产生清晰感、困惑感甚至是存在主义恐惧的时期。而现在这种情况发生得更早了。人们的积极性降低了。问题在于，我们并没有看到中年低谷期发生太大的变化。处于后半生的人们其实仍在经历着大致相同水平的幸福感，这是一件好事。但这确实表明了一个显著的转变。二十岁出头的幸福高潮不再是、不再是常态了。
happiness feels harder in our 20s for a lot of reasons. Things that aren't new. You know, there's this massive social displacement or social splintering where all our structures of friendship just kind of like explode the moment that we graduate high school or uni. And, you know, we are expected to do so many things at once. Build a life. Build a career. Build new social circles. Build a primary, stable, romantic relationship.
由于许多原因，在二十多岁时，我们觉得幸福变得更加困难。这些并不是什么新鲜事。你知道，这里存在着巨大的社会流离或社会分裂，以至于在我们高中或大学毕业的那一刻，我们所有的友情结构都直接土崩瓦解了。而且，你知道的，我们被期望同时做好多事情。建立生活。建立事业。建立新的社交圈。建立一段稳固的主要恋爱关系。
Also whilst we're in like a new, you know, environment also meant to build like financial. wealth. And so I think that a lot of us are really, really struggling and a lot of us are really thinking, like, oh my God, is this like the next 40 years of my life? Not necessarily the case. A lot of people think about that U-turn of happiness or that U-shape of happiness and think like, all right, cool, once I turn 30, it all goes downhill. But it is important to remember that this is a model. It's not an individual diagnostic thing. tool. It's not saying that every single person's life will follow this like peak in 20s, drop down in your 40s and 50s and then come back up in your like 60s and 70s. It's just saying
同时，当我们处在一个新的环境时，我们也被要求创造财富。所以我想，我们中的很多人真的在苦苦挣扎，很多人都在想，哦天哪，这难道就是我未来40年的生活吗？其实并不一定如此。许多人想到了幸福的“U型转弯”或幸福的“U型曲线”，然后心想，好吧，酷，一旦我三十岁，一切就走下坡路了。但必须记住，这只是一个模型。它不是一个针对个人的诊断工具。它并不是说每个人的生活都会遵循这样一个规律：二十几岁时达到顶峰，四五十岁时跌入谷底，然后在六七十岁时回升。它只是说
that in terms of a collective, if we would have put 100,000 people in the room and plot their happiness, there would be this general kind of flow or general pattern. Doesn't mean that you can't be the outlier, doesn't mean that people don't shift up and down that scale over the years. Like, you may have like a really great year at 45 and then, you know, at 46 you get fired and the average of that is kind of in the middle. It doesn't mean that there is a lack of positive emotions in midlife. I really don't want that to spread. Like, people are still experiencing happiness despite the model saying that there is a dip. The dip doesn't go below 50. So it is like people are still on the up, mostly happy.
从群体角度来看，如果我们把十万人聚在一个房间里并绘制他们的幸福感曲线，就会出现这种总体的流动趋势或总体模式。这并不意味着你不能成为那个例外，也不意味着随着时间的推移，人们不会在该量表的上下区间浮动。比如，你在45岁时可能度过了非常棒的一年，然后呢，你在46岁时被解雇了，而这的平均值差不多就在中间。这并不意味着中年时期就缺乏积极的情绪。我真的不想让这种说法蔓延开来。你看，尽管模型显示有一个低谷，但人们仍在体验幸福。这个低谷并没有降到50以下。所以这就好比人们依然处于上升期，总体上是快乐的。
But the fact that that's shifting earlier is really showing that the global rate of happiness is kind of diminishing. I just want to make sure that we put that in there so that no one's like sitting here. Maybe on the cusp of 30, maybe on the cusp of their late 20s thinking, oh my God. Wow, I've got to strap in for this like part of the roller coaster. No, absolutely not. There are still joy and great stuff waiting for you. So with that all being said, I do want to break down some of the other key myths that we might be being sold about happiness, whether deliberately and explicitly or kind of implicitly.
但这种幸福感提前发生转变的事实，确实表明全球的幸福水平正在逐渐下降。我只是想确保我们把这点说清楚，免得有人坐在这里，也许正处于三十岁的边缘，也许正处于二十岁末的边缘，心里想着，哦天哪。哇，我得系好安全带迎接过山车般的生活了。不，绝对不是这样。依然有快乐和美好的事物在等着你。所以，说了这么多，我确实想剖析一下我们可能被灌输的关于幸福的其他一些核心迷思，无论是有意且明确的，还是某种程度上潜移默化的。
The first myth being, you can be happy all the time or you can only be happy if things are going really, really great for you. Oh my goodness. If only I had known how false this was. was, it would have saved me a whole lot of confusion and therapy sessions. Specifically, therapy sessions where I would like sit with my therapist and basically be like, please, like, give me the secret to eliminating all non-positive emotions. Like, give me the secret to not being sad. Give me the secret to curing my grief. Surprise, surprise, there was no secret. It's just a part of life. The idea that we should be in a constant state of bliss is not only unrealistic, as I think we have all learned. It's also deeply unhealthy. Life is a full spectrum of emotions. And to be truly human,
第一个迷思是：你可以一直保持快乐，或者只有当事情对你非常非常顺利时，你才能快乐。哦天哪。要是我早知道这是假的就好了，这能省去我一大堆困惑和心理咨询。具体来说，就是那些我坐在心理医生面前，基本上就像是在说：求求你，告诉我消除所有消极情绪的秘诀吧。给我一个秘诀，让我不再难过。给我一个治愈悲伤的秘诀。然而惊喜吧，根本没有什么秘诀。这只是生活的一部分。我们应该处于持续的极乐状态这种想法，正如我们大家所认为的那样，不仅不切实际，而且非常不健康。生活是全光谱的情绪。要真正成为一个完整的人，
I think you realize this, like the older you get is to experience them all, that's like the whole point. The modern obsession that we have with like perpetual positivity sets us up for failure. It also leads to a lack of what psychologists call emo diversity. We've talked about this on the podcast before, but let's just revisit it. So there was this groundbreaking study published in the journal of experimental psychology back in 2014, so over a decade ago now, that introduced this concept of emo diversity. And it drew an analogy from the environment and from ecology. Just as biodiversity, we know is totally crucial for a healthy ecosystem. Like, you need the bugs, you need the dirt, you need the swamps to have the pretty birds and the bees and the flowers. Emotiversity
我想你会意识到这一点，随着年龄的增长，体验所有这些情绪才是全部的意义所在。我们对持续积极状态的现代执念让我们注定失败。这也导致了心理学家所说的“情绪多样性”（emo diversity）的缺乏。我们之前在播客中讨论过这个，但让我们重温一下。早在2014年，也就是十多年前，发表在《实验心理学杂志》上的一项具有突破性的研究引入了“情绪多样性”的概念。它借鉴了环境学和生态学的类比。正如我们所知，生物多样性对健康的生态系统绝对至关重要。比如，你需要虫子、泥土、沼泽，才能拥有美丽的鸟儿、蜜蜂和花朵。情绪多样性
points to the fact that we need a variety and relative abundance of emotions for psychological health. Basically, you need the disgust, you need the fear, you need the embarrassment, the sadness, to have the amusement, the awe, the hope, the gratitude. The researchers which were led by Dr. Jordy Quaidback found that people who experienced a wide range of both positive and so-called negative emotions, they were actually less likely to suffer from depression. And they were more of, I would say, better equipped to handle life's challenges, which is so counter to, I guess, what I once believed, what a lot of us believe, that is to be happy, you must experience as much happiness as possible. You have to load it up.
则指出这样一个事实：为了心理健康，我们需要各种各样且数量相对充足的情绪。基本上，你需要厌恶、恐惧、尴尬、悲伤，才能拥有娱乐、敬畏、希望和感激。由乔迪·奎德巴克（Jordy Quaidback）博士领导的研究人员发现，那些体验到广泛的积极情绪和所谓的消极情绪的人，实际上更不容易患上抑郁症。而且他们可以说是更有能力应对生活中的挑战，这与我曾经相信的、我们许多人所相信的观点截然相反——即要获得快乐，你必须体验尽可能多的快乐。你必须把它加满。
You have to make it like burst at the seams. Like, this is an equation where the more of one thing, the more happiness you have, the more the output will be a happy one. That doesn't seem to be the case. What they found time and time again, the takeaway. way is that you need to be in touch with all different sides of yourself and how you respond to certain hard and great things in order to feel good. All of our emotions serve a purpose. Suppressing them firstly just means that they're going to crop up when you least expect them and don't want to deal with them and you won't have the skills to deal with them. But also you'll
你必须让它溢出来。就像这是一个方程式，某种东西越多，你拥有的快乐越多，产出的结果就会越快乐。事实似乎并非如此。他们一次又一次发现的结论是：为了感觉良好，你需要与自己所有不同的侧面保持联系，并了解你如何应对某些艰难和美好的事物。我们所有的情绪都有其目的。首先，压抑情绪意味着它们会在你最意想不到、最不想处理的时候冒出来，而且你将没有应对它们的技能。但同时你也会
miss out on the fact that, you know, sadness and grief is a sign that true love and deep love has been in your life. You know, anger can motivate you to confront injustice. Anxiety is like a great warning system for threats or the sign that something in your life needs to change. These are all messengers. They are all crucial parts of our emo diversity, of our emotional ecosystem. So when you just chase constant happiness, it might actually lead you to emotional suppression and it might actually make it harder for you to be happy in the long term. myth too which is kind of similar is when I get this or when I get there or when I get that I will be happy viewing happiness as a destination I think we've all said it before like okay I just
错过这样一个事实，即悲伤和痛苦是你的生活中曾有过真爱和深爱的标志。（你知道的）愤怒可以激励你对抗不公。焦虑就像是应对威胁的绝佳预警系统，或者表明你生活中的某些事情需要改变。这些都是信使。它们都是我们情绪多样性、我们的情绪生态系统中至关重要的部分。所以，当你只是一味追求持续的快乐时，它实际上可能会导致你的情绪压抑，甚至可能让你在长期内更难感到快乐。第二个迷思其实与之类似，那就是：当我得到了这个，或者当我到达了那里，或者当我得到了那个时，我就会快乐。把幸福视为一个终点，我想我们以前都说过这样的话，比如，好吧，我只需要
need to get this promotion and then I'll be super happy um when I get the boyfriend the girlfriend the partner like everything's going to lock into gear for me I just need to get past this bad period at work I just need to fix this thing I just need to achieve that thing I just need to master literally everything. This belief, I'm going to just say it loud and clear, is a trap and it is a common one at that. Once we get to that point that we have put and we have fantasized about, we put so much of our promise for the future in, the goalpost just moves further and moves further and it moves further and further and we have this thing that we've so desired and we've realized that we've placed a lot of our bets on this thing, making life better.
得到这个晋升，然后我就会超级快乐；嗯，当我找到男朋友、女朋友、伴侣时，一切都会为我步入正轨；我只需要度过工作中的这段糟糕时期；我只需要修复这件事；我只需要实现那个目标；我只需要掌握字面意义上的所有事情。我在这里要大声而明确地指出，这种信念是一个陷阱，而且是一个很常见的陷阱。一旦我们达到了我们所寄予厚望、充满幻想、并将未来的大部分期望都押在上面的那个点时，目标就会进一步移动，再进一步移动，不断地向前移动。我们得到了我们梦寐以求的东西，却发现我们把太多的赌注押在了这件事情上，以为它会让生活变得更好。
meanwhile the foundation around it is not there for us to actually be happy. This concept, it's known as hedonic adaptation. Basically, we get used to both positive and negative circumstances. So even if a really great thing happens to you, it still doesn't always feel like it means a lot long term. And you basically get used to the happiness that initially elicited. So this concept was first proposed by. the psychologist Donald Campbell, Philip Brickman, I think in like the 1970s. And the basis for this concept was a really famous study on lottery winners and accident victims, two sides of like
与此同时，它周围的基础并不存在，无法让我们真正快乐。这个概念被称为“享乐适应”（hedonic adaptation）。基本上，我们习惯了积极和消极的环境。所以，即使一件非常棒的事情发生在你身上，从长远来看，它往往还是不觉得意味着很多。并且你基本上会习惯它最初引发的幸福感。这个概念最早是由心理学家唐纳德·坎贝尔（Donald Campbell）、菲利普·布里克曼（Philip Brickman）在20世纪70年代左右提出的。该概念的基础是对彩票中奖者和事故受害者（这光谱的两端）进行的一项非常著名的研究。
this spectrum. And they found that, you know, whilst the lottery winners experienced this like initial surge in happiness and accident victims experienced a deep drop in their well-being, over time, both groups tended to return to their original happiness baseline, that same happiness set point that we mentioned earlier. Our brains, they have this remarkable ability to adapt to new circumstances, both good and bad, which is a great thing. You know, it also means that when terrible things happen, hopefully a lot of people can rebound. So, you know, whilst achieving a goal might give you a great rush, we do quickly get used
他们发现，虽然彩票中奖者经历了幸福感的最初激增，而事故受害者经历了幸福感的急剧下降，但随着时间的推移，这两类人群往往都会回到他们最初的幸福基线上，也就是我们前面提到的那个幸福设定点。我们的大脑具有非凡的适应新环境的能力，无论是好是坏，这其实是一件好事。这也意味着，当可怕的事情发生时，希望很多人能够反弹。所以，尽管实现一个目标可能会给你带来巨大的冲动，但我们很快就会习惯
to it and we start looking for the next thing to make. make us happy. The new car, the new fancy gadget, the new relationship. Yeah, it feels amazing at first. The novelty then wears off. You know, I always use the analogy of like getting a new piece of clothing and being like, yes, finally, my closet is complete. Do you ever have this feeling where you're like, oh yes, finally, I don't need to buy any more clothes. I have everything I need, everything that I thought the best wardrobe would have. And then like, you wear it a few times, you get sick of the next piece, and you're like, oh my God, I don't have any clothes. Like, I know it's a silly analogy, but that's the same thing that's happening here.
它，并开始寻找下一件能让我们快乐的事。新车、新奇的小玩意、新恋情。是的，一开始感觉棒极了。但新鲜感随后就会消退。我总是用买一件新衣服并觉得“耶，终于，我的衣橱完美了”来做比喻。你有没有过这种感觉，就像“哦耶，终于，我不需要再买任何衣服了。我拥有了我所需要的一切，拥有了我认为最好的衣橱该有的一切”。然后呢，你穿了几次，你就厌倦了下一件衣服，然后你会想：“哦天哪，我没有衣服穿了。”我知道这是一个愚蠢的比喻，但这和这里发生的事情是一样的。
Obviously, that doesn't mean, like, give up on working towards things you want or achieving goals or, you know, giving yourself a sweet treat or, like, a fun little prize every now and again. Not at all. Like, these are all important contributions, but they are not the foundation and they cannot be happiness as only sustenance. It's like when you only focus on the. external stuff, it's like trying to build a house by starting with decorations or starting with the wallpaper or the furniture when you don't even have the walls yet. It is a much more internal experience or a daily habit than a one-off. And that's probably counter to what we've been taught, but it's important that we know that. Now, I mentioned lottery winners before. They actually come up quite a bit
当然，这并不意味着放弃为想要的事物努力、实现目标，或者偶尔给自己一份甜蜜的treat或有趣的小奖励。完全不是。这些都是重要的贡献，但它们不是基础，也不能成为幸福的唯一滋养。这就好像当你只关注外部事物时，就像在连墙壁都还没有的时候，试图从装饰、壁纸或家具开始建房子一样。它是一种更多源于内在的体验，或者是一种日常习惯，而不是一次性的。这可能与我们受到的教育相反，但了解这一点很重要。现在，我之前提到了彩票中奖者。事实证明，当人们研究幸福时，他们实际上经常出现，特别是当人们想要回答这个问题时：金钱能让我们更幸福吗？好吧，我不知道你是否已经知道了答案。你可能知道，也可能不知道，但你可能并不了解这个答案背后的所有研究。所以请继续关注我们。我们稍后将讨论这个以及更多内容。2%。
when people research happiness, as it turns out, especially when people want to answer this question. Does money make us happier? Well, I don't know if you already know the answer. You may or may not, but you may not know all the research behind the answer. So stay with us. We're going to talk about that and so much more in just a second. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
请收听《2%》。即IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方的“T-W-O-Persent”。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她说法中明显的前后矛盾。由此开始了长达数年的诉讼战以证明真相。
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
你篡改了这个特定的测试两次。塞伦斯，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支由互联网侦探组成的军队来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税金被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。
You doctored this particular test twice. sell-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
格雷格，一个同性恋者，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着季数的推进，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。
Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。请在Iheart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，千万不要惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，千万。也别惹她的朋友。我们总是这么说，相信你的女朋友们。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never. mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends.
我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在新一季的《女朋友们》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意，所以他们决定自己动手。我说，哦，见鬼，不。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。
I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target.
他将得到他应得的。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。你还记得黛安·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小姬姆（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小姬姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克（Sam Jek）。我是亚历克斯·英格利希（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会邀请你来到这里，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集马特·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅谈80年代的快克可卡因（crack）。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s.
需要明确的是，84年对我很重要不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备谈论快克，但只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始发现这里有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆上桌面了。然后你结束了那句话。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
To be clear, 84 is big to me not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
人们。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。所以我们正在剖析一些关于幸福的迷思，这就把我们带到了其中最重要的一项，即迷思三：金钱会让我更快乐。我们都听过这样的说法，比如钱买不到幸福，或者钱能买到幸福。我不知道你听到的是哪一种，但其中哪一个才是真的呢？所以你需要知道的是，如果你想回答这个问题，你需要了解由诺贝尔奖获得者、来自普林斯顿大学的丹尼尔·卡尼曼（Daniel Kahneman）和安格斯·迪顿（Angus Deaton）在2010年进行的一项非常著名的研究，我本来想说哥伦比亚大学的，但是来自
people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So we're breaking down some of the myths of happiness, which brings us to one of the most significant, which is myth three, money will make me happier. We've all heard that phrase, like, money can't buy you happiness or money can buy you happiness. I don't know which way you are hearing it, but which one of those is true? So what you need to know, if you want to answer this question, is you need to know of a very famous 2010 study done by Nobel Prize winners, Daniel Kaman, and Angus Staten from Princeton, Princeton University, I was going to say Columbia, but from
普林斯顿大学，他们基本上是为了回答这个问题。他们真的想一劳永逸地调查这件事，给我们一个明确的答案。他们发现的是，情感幸福感确实会随着收入的增加而上升，直到某一个点。在2010年，这个点在美国是每年75,000美元，如果算上通货膨胀，现在大约是110,000美元。超过这个点后，更多的钱似乎不会对人们日常的幸福感产生显著影响。这是因为拥有足够的钱来满足我们的基本需求，并且能够舒适地生活而没有账单和经济不安全感的压力。这最初对我们的福祉具有改变生活的巨大影响。
Princeton University, which basically, they wanted to answer this question. They wanted to really just like, for once and for all, investigate this, give us a clear answer. And what they found was that, emotional well-being does tend to rise with income up until a point. And that point in the year 2010 was $75,000 a year in the US, which is about $110,000 now when we calculate for inflation. Beyond that point, more money didn't seem to make a significant difference to people's daily feelings of happiness. This is because having enough money to meet our basic needs and to comfortably without the stress of bills and financial insecurity. That initially has a huge life-changing impact on our well-being.
我前几天实际上在听喜剧演员罗比·霍夫曼（Robbie Hoffman）谈论这个。我认为她是活着的最搞笑的人。我发现她绝对滑稽，但她是在非常非常贫困的环境中长大的。我想她是十个孩子中的一个，她坦率地谈到当她开始作为喜剧演员、作家和演员赚钱时。这如何改变了她的生活。但她说：“你知道的，现在我有很多富有的朋友，他们赚了更多的钱，他们说：‘哦，是的，我其实没有经历过那种情况。我一直都挺好的，也挺稳定的。’他们说，这其实并没有
I was actually listening to the comedian Robbie Hoffman talk about this the other day. I think she is the funniest person alive. I find her absolutely hilarious, but she grew up really, really poor. I think she was like one of ten kids and she like spoke really candidly about how when she started making money as a comedian and as a writer and as an actress. like that changed her life. But she was like, you know, I have a lot of now I have a lot of rich friends who have come into even more money and they're like, oh yeah, I didn't really experience that. Like I was always kind of okay and kind of stable and they're like, this didn't really
改变我什么。”你知道的，除了基本需求加上一些娱乐资金、非必需品、可能还有一些旅行之外，金钱无法减轻那些原本就存在的问题，尤其是对于那些本就在苦苦挣扎的人来说。2018年的一项最新研究实际上为这一点增添了一个迷人的细微差别。他们发现，虽然高收入人群往往会体验到更多以自我为中心的积极情绪，比如自豪感或成就感，但低收入人群更有可能体验到更多与他人相关的积极情绪，如爱与同情。在这篇论文中，
change anything to me. You know, beyond the basic needs plus some fun money, some non-essentials, maybe some travel, money cannot alleviate the problems that were already there, especially for people who were already struggling. A more recent 2018 study actually adds a fascinating nuance to this. They found that whilst people with higher incomes tend to experience more positive
它发表在《情感》（Emotion）杂志上。这些研究得出结论，我引用原话：“似乎情况是这样的，你的财富使你倾向于不同种类的幸福。虽然富有的人可能会在他们的成就、地位和个人成就中找到更多的积极性，但不那么富有的人似乎在他们的关系、照顾他人和与他人联系的能力中找到更多的积极性和幸福感。”对我来说，我不知道你怎么想，
emotions centered on themselves like pride or a sense of accomplishment, lower income people are more likely to experience more positive emotions related to others like love and compassion. In this paper,
这听起来像是一种更加丰富和持久的幸福。我知道这听起来很老套，对不起，但如果你没有可以分享的人，成就又有什么意义呢？当我出版我的书时，我感到了这一点，对吧？是的，出版一本书很棒。我感到了强烈的自豪感。但随后我可以和我的朋友、家人以及那些在我这样做时给予我帮助并为支持我做出如此惊人事情的人们一起举办一场盛大的派对。
it was published in the journal Emotion. these research has concluded, and I quote, what seems to be the case is that your wealth predisposes you to different kinds of happiness. Whilst wealthy individuals may find greater positivity in their accomplishments, status and individual achievements, less wealthy individuals seem to find more positivity and happiness in their relationships, their ability to care for and ability to connect to others, which to me, I don't know about you,
那是我生命中最美好的一天。太棒了，我能够（你知道的）和他们一起完成这件事，并且能够有一个开放式酒吧，和他们一起大声畅饮、吃蛋糕。而且，你知道的，这比这一切的个人成就更有意义。我要说的是，金钱可能买不到幸福。为了唱反调，它确实能买到便利，这实际上可能会给你更多的时间去陪伴你重视的人，去做你喜欢的事，这确实对整体的幸福感有所贡献。例如，你知道的，如果你负担得起在线购买杂货的额外费用，这意味着你有更多的时间陪伴孩子，你可能会更快乐。或者如果你能坐优步而不是公共交通，这意味着你在早晨有更多时间慢下来
that sounds like a much more enriching and sustainable sorts of happiness. It's going to, I know, I'm sorry, it's going to sound cliche, but what is the point of an accomplishment if you don't have anyone to share it with? I felt this like when I published my book, right? Yeah, it was great publishing a book. And I felt such a sense of pride. But then I got to do this whole big party with like my friends and my family and the people who had helped me and done such amazing things to support me whilst I was doing that.
或者早点到达某个活动现场，或者花时间进行自我护理，你会更快乐。但在某些阶段，它可能也会孤立你，这就是为什么我认为许多富人只和有钱人做朋友。我有点好奇，你知道的，他们没钱时或者苦苦挣扎时的那些朋友怎么了。那些人去哪儿了？就像人们总是疑惑的那样，
That was like the best day of my life. Like that was amazing that I got to, you know, do that with them and got to like have an open bar and like shout some drinks and eat cake with them. And, you know, that was more meaningful than the individual accomplishment of it all. I will say the thing is, is that money may not buy happiness. To play devil's advocate, it does buy convenience, which may actually give you more time to be around the people you value and to do the things that you love, which does. contribute overall to happiness. For example, you know, if you can afford to buy groceries online at that extra cost, meaning you have more time to spend with your kids, you probably will be happier. Or if you can Uber rather than public transport, meaning you have more time in the morning to slow down
我前几天在Instagram上看到这个，就像黛安·莉珀（Dea Leeper）和她儿时朋友去度假时，她会付钱吗？还是他们付钱？在某种程度上，我认为金钱也会成为一堵在人与人之间树立起来的砖墙。因此，如果幸福不是关于追逐金钱，不是关于追逐持续的快乐，
or to get to a function early or to like spend time on self-care, you will be happier. But at some stage, it probably also isolates you, which is why I think a lot of rich people are only friends with other rich people. And like I kind of wonder, you know, what happened to like the people they were friends with when they had no money or when they were really struggling. Where did those people kind of go? It's like when people always wonder,
不是关于追逐外部成就，我们究竟能做些什么来培养它，以反驳那些每个人都说能帮助我们的观点呢？所以我将为你提供四个切实可行的、当然也是有心理学依据的策略，它们超越了写日记和锻炼（我们知道这些很重要），希望能以一种非常深远的方式丰富你的生活。至少我希望如此。所以我现在想给你两个短期工具和两个长期工具，从我的第一个工具开始，那就是制定一个“幸福蓝图”。我的心理学家实际上教我这个作为品味积极体验的方法。当美好的事情发生时，你得到了赞美，你知道的，你看了一场非常美丽的日落，你喝了一杯非常棒的开胃酒，你（我不知道）遇到了一只非常可爱的收容所狗狗——不要让它就这么过去，停顿一会儿，有意识地专注于感官细节和这一刻唤起的感受，你可以（你知道的）与其他人分享这种经历，你可以把它写在你的备忘录应用里。如果你关注我的Instagram，你知道我会做一件事
I saw this on Instagram the other day, like when Dea Leeper goes on vacation with her like childhood friends, like, does she pay? Like, or do they pay? Like at some point, I think money can also become something that puts, puts like a brick wall between you and other people. So if happiness isn't about chasing money, it isn't about chasing constant pleasure,
叫做“微笑档案”（smile file），每个月我都会拍摄让我微笑的事物，然后把它们放进手机的一个应用里，有时我会分享它们。你甚至可以很简单地在脑海中重温它。这种品味的行为有助于你的大脑巩固积极的记忆，并从那一刻榨取最大的快乐。研究表明，经常品尝积极体验的人（比如吃一口甜点，差不多就是这样），他们报告说有更高水平的幸福感，更低的抑郁水平。从这个品味的时刻开始，你的mind和你的body就会知道快乐意味着什么，实际感觉是什么样的，而不是让快乐仅仅成为一件你没有去
it isn't about chasing external achievements, what can we actually do to cultivate it counter to what everyone's been saying would be able to help us? So I'm going to give you four practical, of course, psychology-backed strategies that go beyond like journaling and exercise, which we know are important, to hopefully like enriches.
集中的稍纵即逝的事情。这就是你的幸福蓝图。你知道，在压力大的时候，当你沮丧时，当你和某人吵架时，当你感到不安时，你其实可以抓住那一刻，把你的思绪拉回并聚焦在那种感官体验上。你实际上可以重温那些感受，它们对你来说更容易触及。就像当你闻到你曾经去过的那个假期的香水味时，你会立刻被带回那里，或者你听一首歌，它把你带了回去。即使你无法身临其境地回到那个记忆发生的地方，如果你已经品味了它，并且如果你已经在记忆中巩固了它，你就可以刻意地回到那种感觉中。接下来，让我们更多地关注如何通过积极建设性回应，让幸福成为一种共享的情感，而不是一种独处练习。因此，当你在乎的人——你的朋友、你的妈妈、你的男友、我不知道、你真正喜欢的同事——与你分享一个好消息时。花一秒钟想想你是如何回应的。有一位心理学家，她的名字叫谢莉·加布尔（Shelley Gable），她对亲密关系进行了所有的研究，她发现人们对好消息有四种常见的反应：积极建设性、消极建设性、积极破坏性和消极破坏性。我们大多数人，即使出于好意，也会陷入消极建设性的类别。
your life in a seriously deep way. At least I hope. So I want to give you two tools for now and two tools for the long term, starting with my first tool, which is to make a happiness blueprint. So my therapist actually taught me this as a way to savor positive experiences. When something good happens, you receive a compliment, you know, you watch a really beautiful sunset, you have like a really amazing like apparel sprits like you I don't know meet a really cute shelter dog like don't just let it pass pause for a moment like consciously focus on the sensory details and the feelings that this moment evokes you can you know share that experience with someone else you can write it down on your notes app if you follow me on instagram you know I do this thing
你的朋友说：“哦天哪，我今天工作过得真好。”然后你说：“哦，太酷了。太棒了。”然后你，就那样了。然后那个朋友就会觉得有点被泼了冷水。相比之下，积极建设性的回应就像那件事发生在你身上一样。你不仅不说恭喜，还会说：“太惊人了。快告诉我全部。你知道，那是什么感觉？”
called a smile file where every month like I um take photos of things that make me smile and I just put them into an app on my phone and then sometimes I'll share them. You can even just like simply replay it in your mind. This act of savoring helps your brain cement the positive memory and extract maximum joy from that moment. Research has shown that people who regularly savor positive experiences like the first bite of a dessert, kind of like that, like they report high levels of happiness, lower levels of depression. from this moment of savoring, your mind and your body then know what it means and what it actually feels like to be happy rather than happiness just being like this fleeting thing that you don't
发生了什么？你老板当时说了什么？我们该怎么庆祝？你知道，当你热情地参与别人的好消息时，它会创造出一个强大的共享积极情感的反馈循环。庆祝的行为让另一个人感到被认可和被看见，这绝对是一场双赢。而这反过来也会放大你自己的快乐。这实际上是一个被称为“资本化”（capitalization）的过程。
concentrate on. This is your happiness blueprint. You know, in times of stress, when you're upset, when you're fighting with someone, when you're uneasy, you can actually take that moment and cast your mind back and just center in that sensory experience. You can actually revisit visit those feelings, they're more accessible to you. It's like when you smell a perfume from like that holiday that you went on and like you're immediately brought back there or you like listen to a song and it brings you back. Even if you can't physically be in that position where that memory took place, if you have savored it and if you have solidified it in your memory, you can return to that feeling deliberately. Next, let's focus more on how we can make happiness a shared
研究证实，热情的反应能让双方都更快乐。我思考它的方式就像一个网球，它变得越来越快，越来越快。就像你在两个人之间来回击球。就像，哦天哪，这速度。就像它在上升，每个人都很兴奋，它放大了这种体验，而不仅仅是一个人击球。它快速地飞了一会儿，然后就弹开了。你必须去做那种追球的事情。如果你看过电影《挑战者》（Challengers），里面有一个场景，好吧，就是那个场景，那部电影的那个场景。
emotion rather than a solitary practice by really engaging in active constructive responding. So when someone you really care about your friend, your mom, your boyfriend, I don't know, a colleague you really like, shares a piece of good news with you. Take a second to think about how you respond. There is a psychologist, her name is Shelley Gable, and she has done all this research on close relationships, and she's found four common responses that people will have to good news. active constructive, passive constructive, active destructive, and passive destructive. Most of us, even with good intentions, we fall into the passive constructive category.
这完全就是我想象中情感资本化过程的样子。接下来是关于长期的两个小贴士。我有点喜欢我们一直在进行的“幸福是共享的情感”这个主题。所以我们要继续保持这个主题，并谈谈利他消费（pro-social spending）的好处。我们显然已经打破了金钱能买到真正的幸福这个迷思，但研究确实表明，你如何花钱可以显著影响你的幸福感。几年前伊丽莎白·邓恩（Elizabeth Dunn）做过一系列研究。它们发表在《科学》杂志上，基本上他们说，不是有钱让你更快乐。你如何花钱
Your friend's like, oh my God, I had this really great day at work and you're like, oh, that's so cool. That's great. And then you, that's it. And that friend like kind of feels a little bit shut down. In contrast, active constructive is responding like that thing happened to you. Instead of just saying congrats, you'd be like, that's amazing. Like, tell me everything. You know, what was it like?
才是关键所在。他们引入了“利他消费”这个概念。基本上，他们发现那些被随机分配把少量钱花在别人身上的个人，走出实验时的感觉比那些只把钱花在自己身上的人要快乐得多。这一发现在各种文化、各种收入水平、各种性别和年龄中也得到了复制。这不是关于把大量的钱花在
What happened? What did your boss say then? How should we celebrate? You know, when you enthusiastically engage with someone else's good news, it creates a really powerful feedback loop of shared positive emotion. The act of celebration makes the other person feel validated and seen that's a total win. And that in turns amplifies like the joy for you as well. It's like a process called capitalization, actually.
奢华的礼物上，或者把所有的钱都捐给慈善机构。这是关于给朋友买杯咖啡，你知道的，在周五请大家喝饮料，向慈善机构捐款，给你的姐姐或母亲买个小饰品因为这让你想起了她们，或者（你知道的）留下一点额外的慷慨小费。把钱花在别人身上会持续激活大脑的奖励中心，产生这种给予的温暖光芒。我想你知道我在说什么。利他消费也增强了我们的社会联系。它赋予了我们作为善良和慷慨之人的身份认同。它使我们的关系更牢固，这些都是持久幸福的关键成分。这里有一个重要的警告，尽管我们很喜欢利他消费，但如果你打算这样做
And the research confirms enthusiastic responses make both people happier. The way that I think about it is like a tennis ball that gets like faster and faster and faster. It's like you hit it back and forth between two people. Like it's like, oh my God, the speed. It's like going up and like everyone's excited and it's magnifying this like experience rather than just like one person hitting it. And it like goes really fast for a second and then it just like kind of bounces away. and you have to do that thing when you chase the ball. If you've ever watched challenges, there is like one scene, well, the scene, the scene of that movie.
的话，请确保它在你的经济能力之内。如果它会导致经济困难，它显然会产生相反的效果。而且至关重要的一点是，不要抱着想要得到回报的心态去做，因为那实际上会产生大量的怨恨。这是我从小到大我妈妈一直对我说的一句话。如果你打算做一件好事，那项行为中最美好的部分就是不期望得到任何回报。你必须这么做，仅仅是因为你想这么做，而他们永远无法回报你，也从未做出任何回应。那也没关系。没关系。最后，我们关于幸福的最终建议是为你的生活培养一个连贯的叙事。
That is exactly how I imagine this process of emotional capitalization. So next are two tips for the longer term. I'm kind of liking this happiness is a shared emotion theme we have going on. So we're going to keep that going and talk about the benefits of pro-series. spending. We have obviously debunked the myth that money can buy true happiness, but research does suggest that how you spend your money can significantly impact your well-being. There was a series of studies done a couple of years ago by Elizabeth Dunn. They were published in the journal Science magazine, and basically they said that it's not having money that makes you happier. How you spend it
为你的生活写一个故事。我们的大脑喜欢故事，我们对自己关于幸福、复原力以及这一切历程的叙事是极其重要的。培养叙事的做法，本质上意味着我们审视自己的经历，并刻意反思为什么这不仅仅是一系列随机事件，而是这一切都包含着意义，每一件事，甚至是艰难的事情，都必然会发生。现在，这并不是说一切发生都有原因。它是说事情发生了，然后我可以应用一个原因，我可以为这些体验应用一种旅程地图。一堆研究人员对此进行了研究。他们中的许多人发现，当你帮助或鼓励人们将自己的生活视为
is really like, that's the kicker. And they introduced this concept of pro-social spending. Basically, they found that individuals who were randomly assigned to spend a small amount of money on others walked out of that experiment feeling a lot happier than those who, you know, just spent the money on themselves. This finding has also been replicated across various cultures, across various income levels, across various genders and ages. It's not about spending tons of money on.
带不同章节的故事，或者将生活中的所有积极和消极事物视为朝着某个方向发展、具有意义，并且所有这些时刻都很重要（即使它们很糟糕）。他们确实感到更快乐，并且能够重新构架逆境时刻，不是将其视为随机的悲剧，而是视为重要的转折点，帮助他们恢复自主感并让他们觉得自己有控制力。你赋予你的生活一种意义感。你赋予你的生活一种目标感。
lavish gifts or giving away all your money to charity. It's about buying a friend of coffee, you know, shouting around a drinks on a Friday, donating to charity, buying like a small trinket for your sister or for your mother because it made you think of them or, you know, leaving just like a little bit of an extra generous tip. Spending money on others consistently activates the brain's reward centres, producing this like warm glow of giving. And I think you know what I'm talking about. Pro-social spending also strengthens our social bonds. It gives us a sense of identity as a kind and a generous person. It makes our relationship stronger, all key ingredients for lasting happiness. An important caveat here, though, as much as we love pro-social spending, if you're going to engage
比如送昂贵的礼物或把所有的钱捐给慈善机构。这只是关于给朋友买杯咖啡，你知道，周五请大家喝一杯，向慈善机构捐款，给姐姐或妈妈买个小饰品，因为这让你想起了她们，或者，你知道，留下一点格外慷慨的小费。为他人花钱会持续激活大脑的奖励中心，产生这种给予带来的“温暖光芒”。我想你知道我在说什么。亲社会消费还能增强我们的社会纽带。它赋予我们作为善良和慷慨之人的认同感。它让我们的关系更加紧密，这些都是持久幸福的关键要素。不过，这里有一个重要的注意事项，尽管我们喜欢亲社会消费，但如果你要进行
in this, like, please just make sure it's within your means. Like, if it's going to lead to financial struggle, it's obviously going to have the opposite effect. And also, crucially, don't do it with the thought that you want something in return because that will actually create a lot of resentment. This is something my mom has said to me since I was a child. If you are going to do something nice, the nicest part of that act is not expecting anything in return. You've got to just do it because you want to and they could never pay you back and never do anything in response. That's fine. That's fine. Finally, our final tip for happiness is to cultivate a coherent narrative for your life.
这种消费，请确保在你的能力范围内。如果它会导致经济困境，显然会产生相反的效果。而且至关重要的是，不要抱着想要回报的想法去做，因为那实际上会产生很多怨恨。这是我从小到大我妈妈一直对我说的话。如果你要做一件好事，那项行为最美好的部分就是不期望任何回报。你必须只是因为你想这么做而去做，哪怕他们永远无法回报你，也从不做任何回应。没关系，没关系。最后，我们关于幸福的最后一个建议是为你的生活培养一个连贯的叙事。
Make a story of your life. Our brains love stories and the story we tell ourselves about our happiness and about our resilience and about, you know, the journey of it all is incredibly important. The practice of like cultivating a narrative, essentially it means that we look at our experiences and we intentionally reflect on perhaps why this is not just a series of random events, but all of this contains meaning and everything, even the hard things had to happen. Now, it's not saying that everything happens for a reason. It's saying that things happen and then I can apply a reason and I can apply a kind of journey map to those experiences. A bunch of researchers have looked into this. A bunch of them have found that when you help or encourage people to see their life as kind of
编织你人生的故事。我们的大脑喜欢故事，我们对自己讲述的关于幸福、韧性以及这一切旅程的故事极其重要。培养叙事的实践，本质上意味着我们审视自己的经历，并有意地反思：为什么这不仅仅是一系列随机事件，这一切都包含着意义，每一件事，甚至艰难的事情都是必经之路。现在，这并不是说一切发生都有原因。它是说事情发生了，然后我可以赋予一个原因，我可以为这些经历绘制一张旅程图。许多研究人员对此进行了研究。他们中的许多人发现，当你帮助或鼓励人们将他们的生活视为一种
a bit of a story with different chapters or to see their life containing all the positive and negative things as going somewhere and as having meaning and all those moments as being important even if they sucked. They do feel happier and they're able to reframe moments of adversity, not as like random tragedies, but as really pivotal turning points that help them return to a sense of agency and make them feel like they have control. You give your life a sense of meaning. You give your life a sense of purpose.
带有不同章节的故事，或者将他们的生活视为包含所有积极和消极的事情，认为它们正朝着某个方向发展并具有意义，所有这些时刻都是重要的，即使它们很糟糕。他们确实会感到更快乐，并且能够重新构筑逆境的时刻，不是将其视为随机的悲剧，而是视为真正关键的转折点，帮助他们恢复自主感并让他们觉得一切尽在掌握。你赋予了你的生活一种意义感。你赋予了你的生活一种目标感。
If we're going to return all the way back to that initial model of happiness, the perma model, those are two really foundational things that I think a lot of us have kind of lost as we've become less religious and less spiritual. And we've noticed that impact.
如果我们一直追溯回最初的幸福模型，即 PERMA 模型，我认为有两点非常基础的东西，在我们变得越来越不笃信宗教、越来越缺乏精神寄托的过程中，其实已经被我们弄丢了很多。而且我们已经注意到了这种影响。
We've noticed that when you don't have a sense of meaning or coherence to your life, it all feels kind of random. It feels harder to feel, feel happy about your circumstances. So that is my final, final tip. Ultimately, like to wrap the episode up, I think the biggest conclusion you can take away
我们注意到，当你生活中缺乏一种意义感或连贯性时，一切都会显得有点随机。你会觉得很难对自己的处境感到幸福。所以这就是我最后、最后的建议。总的来说，如果要为这期节目做个总结，我认为你可以带走的最大结论是
is that science tells us that happiness is, it's going to sound so cheesy. I'm sorry, bear with me, but it's not the destination. It's the journey. I'm sorry, I know it's so cheesy. And it's also not about having happiness all the time. It's about savoring it when you do. And, you know, for my 20-something listeners,
科学告诉我们，幸福它——听起来可能会有点俗气。我很抱歉，请忍耐一下，但它不是终点。它是旅程。对不起，我知道这太俗气了。而且这也不是指你要一直拥有幸福。而是当幸福降临的时候，去细细品味它。而且，你知道的，对于我二十几岁的听众来说，
which is probably all of you, it's okay if these are not your happiest years. Like I've definitely had some freaking dark times in my 20s, which are well documented on the podcast. Um, so if you're really struggling at the moment and thinking like this is it, this is the happiness drop off they all talk about. Firmly and resoundingly, that is not the case. Not at all. This is a hard period of life because you don't have as many emotional and financial resources that you will hopefully have the older you get. And a lot of it will get easier. You will gain coping skills. And a lot of it is, again, just part of the story. It's part of the story of gaining resilience.
这可能也就是你们所有人，即使这些年不是你最幸福的时光，也没关系。比如，我在二十几岁的时候确实经历过一些非常黑暗的时期，这些在播客里都有据可查。嗯，所以如果你现在真的很挣扎，觉得这就是全部了，这就是大家都在谈论的幸福悬崖。坚决而肯定地，事实并非如此。根本不是这样。这是一段艰难的人生时期，因为你没有随着年龄增长后有望拥有的那么多情感和财务资源。而且很多事情会变得更容易。你会获得应对技巧。而且很多事情，再次强调，只是故事的一部分。这是获得韧性这一故事的一部分。
It's part of the story of reconnecting with real happiness. And, you know, that's the thing about happiness. I can give you all the psychological strategies and tips and research and whatever. Happiness is just sometimes so freaking random. And it just like shows up. on a Wednesday night and just shows its face and it's like, oh, hey, and you just suddenly feel great. Or like, it just randomly shows up on a Saturday evening or a Saturday morning and you didn't do anything differently, you didn't plan for it and it's just there. So, like, hold out for those moments, like hold out for those glimmers, right? Because they do come around and when they do, savor it. Like, I had this amazing day the other day and it just, just super
这是与真正的幸福重新建立联系的故事的一部分。而且，你知道，这就是幸福奇妙的地方。我可以给你所有的心理学策略、建议、研究以及诸如此类的东西。但幸福有时就是这么随机。它可能就出现在一个周三的晚上，露出了它的面容，然后就像在说，哦，嘿，你突然就感觉好极了。或者，它可能随机地出现在一个周六的晚上或周六的早晨，你什么也没做错，你没有为它做计划，它就那么在那里。所以，去等待那些时刻，去等待那些微光，对吧？因为它们确实会出现，当它们出现时，好好品味它。就像，前几天我过了美好的一天，它非常
random, did not set out to have a great day, just happened. And I was like, oh my God. I've got to really make sure that I remember this. And, you know, it was helpful to, like, return to it in the kind of weeks to follow it and be like, yeah, my God, I'm excited for another day like that. And isn't it such a nice surprise? Like, I'm not sure when it's going to come, but I know it is. So that's kind of my final message for today's episode. I really hope that you enjoyed it.
随机，并没有刻意去追求拥有美好的一天，只是顺其自然地发生了。当时我想，天哪。我必须确保自己能记住这一点。而且，你知道的，在随后的几周里回味它很有帮助，会觉得，天哪，我很期待再过这样的一天。这难道不是一个如此美好的惊喜吗？虽然我不确定它什么时候会来，但我知道它一定会来。所以这算是今天节目的最后留言。我真的希望你们会喜欢。
I really hope that it's contributed something to your knowledge and to your sense of meaning in life. If you have made it this far, leave a TV show recommendation down below, like the happiest TV show that you know that you always watch when you are in a bad mood. Like, if we're talking about intentional tips for happiness, anytime I'm unhappy, I always watch Modern Family. I love that show. What is your modern family? Maybe it is Modern Family.
我真的希望它能为你们的知识以及你们对人生意义的理解做出一些贡献。如果你听到了这里，在下方留下一个电视剧推荐吧，比如你知道的最幸福的电视剧，每当你心情不好时就会看的那部。比如说，如果我们谈论关于幸福的刻意建议，每当我不开心时，我总是看《摩登家庭》。我太喜欢那个节目了。你的“摩登家庭”是什么？也许它就是《摩登家庭》。
What is your show that you think everyone should watch that always brings you joy? I can't wait to read some of your responses. I need a new TV show. I can't rewatch Modern Family for the 10th time. It's getting a little bit embarrassing. I'm not like a teenager anymore. Like I need to move on. With that in mind, I want to be able to.
你认为每个人都应该看、总能带给你快乐的节目是什么？我迫不及待地想看你们的一些回复了。我需要一部新电视剧。我不能第十次重温《摩登家庭》了。这变得有点尴尬了。我不再是个青少年了。我需要向前看。带着这个想法，我要向……表达感谢
thank our beautiful researcher Libby Colbert for her contributions to this episode. I want to remind you all to follow us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast to make sure that you are following along on Spotify, Apple Podcasts, the IHeart Radio app, wherever you are listening and give us a five-star review, only if you feel called to do so. I appreciate you listening this far. And as always, be kind, be safe, be gentle with yourself. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%.
感谢我们优秀的 研究员 Libby Colbert 对本期节目的贡献。我想提醒大家在 Instagram 上关注我们 @That Psychology Podcast，确保你在 Spotify、Apple Podcasts、IHeart Radio 应用或任何你收听的地方关注我们，并给我们一个五星好评，前提是你觉得应该这么做。我很感激你收听了这么久。像往常一样，保持善良，注意安全，对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist,
我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理坚韧、健身和培养韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更幸福、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即 TWO%，在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，
they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我要成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 上，
wherever you get your podcast on the Look Back at it podcast For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
无论你在哪里收听播客，在《Look Back at it》播客中，对于 1979 年，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84 年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图通过我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家，来理解我们是如何熬过那段时光的。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway
就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代一样。84 年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听的是《Learn the Hardway》
with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability
由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games 主持。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行交流。有多少男人带着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，
that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并不意味着你需要这么做。在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Learn the Hard Way。这是一档 iHeart 播客。人工保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。